forse vi sembrerà strano ma posso
assicurarvi che io e voi
abbiamo molto in comune
al mattino di sentirvi stanchi di non
avere voglia di alzarvi dal letto e non
sentirvi molto motivati motivati bene io
qualche anno fa mi sentivo così
probabilmente ciò era dovuto anche ad
avere dei figli piccoli quando si sa
quando si hanno dei figli piccoli non si
dorme molto però poi ho capito che c'era
anche altro da sempre io è strano perché
avevo il lavoro dei miei sogni lavoro
come ricercatrice universitaria da
quello che avevo sempre desiderato fare
nella mia vita perché io amo tantissimo
fare il mio lavoro di ricerca e amo
tantissimo fare didattica però in quel
momento mi sentivo così da sempre studio
biopolimeri naturali che sono quelle
biomolecole che naturalmente si trovano
negli organismi viventi come ad esempio
le proteine i polisaccaridi i
fosfolipidi e le basi nucleiche spesso
siamo portati a pensare che queste
biomolecole non siano stabili al di
fuori del loro intorno
invece non è vero perché provate a
pensare la lana è costituita da
biopolimeri naturali la seta il cotone
per cui queste due molecole possono
trovare anche applicazioni nell'ambito
dei materiali ed era proprio questa la
linea che mi spingeva ossia utilizzare
queste due molecole nell'ambito dei
materiali e questo mi divertiva molto
ovviamente sempre nell'ambito del lavoro
ero portata a fare didattica e anche
questo lo facevo con la massima passione
però noi siamo portati anche a fare un
compito di terza missione la terza
missione è come il docente universitario
si interfaccia con la società civile e
anche quello che sto facendo oggi in una
mia terza missione e nell'ambito della
terza missione avevo deciso di svolgere
un corso sulle bio classiche per gli
studenti delle scuole superiori così
avrei potuto unire sempre le mie due
passioni
una era quello dello studio dei
biopolimeri naturali perché molto spesso
alcune delle bioplastiche sono
realizzate a partire proprio da
biopolimeri naturali e la seconda è
quella della sostenibilità ambientale
ossia in questo modo avrei potuto
sensibilizzare i ragazzi al problema
della plastica questo già quattro anni
fa quando nessuno ne parlava ma i cui
dati erano già molto allarmanti
ovviamente nella mia mente avevo sempre
in mente di provare a lavorare sulle
bioplastiche però sapete
penso che queste sono idee che possa
rappresentare come delle candele spente
non vi capita mai quante volte siete lì
e di te mi piacerebbe fare questa cosa o
questa idea domani magari inizio parte
lo faccio però prima casa altre quella
scintilla quell'input che vi faccia
accendere realmente quella candela che
ha nella vostra testa bene a me sono
stati due gli eventi che hanno acceso la
scintilla
il primo proprio a scuola un giorno
mentre mi trovavo a fare questo corso
sulle biomolecole un ragazzo si alza mi
disse professoressa quello che dice lei
è bellissimo proprio si vede che ne
parla con una passione enorme ma lei
adesso sta lavorando sulla mole delle
bio classiche mi può dire che cosa sta
facendo e in quel momento rimasi
perplessa perché in quel momento io non
ci stavo lavorando e ho pensato alle
competenze e le conoscenze per poterlo
fare
eppure in questo momento non lo sta
facendo il secondo episodio si è
verificato a casa per svolgere questi
corsi presso le scuole generalmente io
testo le mie lezioni perché sapete fare
lezione all'università è un conto si
utilizza un certo linguaggio una certa
terminologia fare queste elezioni per
dei ragazzi e dei bambini è molto più
difficile per me di conseguenza prova a
farle a casa con i miei bambini e un
giorno mostravo loro un video in cui si
vedevano delle immagini in cui c'erano
dei pesci e delle tartarughe marine
impigliati nella plastica
a un certo punto vedo la mia bambina
grande diventare cupa e il piccolino
inizia a piangere
inizialmente pensavo avessero discusso
tra di loro non pensavo ci fosse una
correlazione tra il video che ho
mostrato e la loro reazione
invece poi il piccolino iniziato a
piangere dicendo che lui voleva andare
in quel mare a prendere quei pesci
perché non era giusto che loro si
trovassero lì in mezzo a tutta quella
plastica e voleva portarli in un mare
pulito
capite bene che questo acceso dentro di
me e non solo una scintilla ma un vero e
proprio incendio
in quel momento ho capito che avrei
voluto dedicare quello che avevo
imparato nel corso di tutti questi anni
a questo scopo e così ho iniziato a
lavorare sulle bioplastiche abbiamo
messo su un team di persone
all'università per svolgere questo
lavoro
e a partire da scarti alimentari siamo
riusciti ad ottenere dei materiali molto
interessanti perché gli scarti
alimentari perché ovviamente utilizzare
coltivazioni agricole
rischia di diciamo utilizzare il suolo e
si può anche togliere l'alimentazione
magari a persone che ne avrebbero
bisogno quindi utilizzare gli scarti
ovvero i rifiuti qualcosa che
costituisce un surplace per la nostra
società diciamo rende questi rifiuti una
risorsa di conseguenza siamo riusciti ad
ottenere in laboratorio un prototipo di
un materiale molto interessante ottenuto
a partire dal latte però solo questo non
basta perché ovviamente avevamo
realizzato un prototipo di laboratorio
io ci credevo ci credo ancora questa
idea ci credo per cui vorrei veramente
vederla in commercio questo materiale
di conseguenza abbiamo pensato di
costituire la startup che si chiama
plastica per poter realizzare delle idee
servono anche delle opportunità e
l'opportunità è nata proprio con la
start cup lazio ovvero è una
competizione per le migliori idee di
impresa nata in un centro di ricerca del
lazio noi abbiamo proposto la nostra
idea
inizialmente così quasi per gioco ve lo
confesso e poi dall invece è andata la
vera e propria valanga
perché non solo abbiamo vinto la
competizione a livello regionale ma da
quel punto abbiamo iniziato a ricevere
tantissimi riconoscimenti in ambito
nazionale abbiamo ricevuto l'attenzione
dei media e vi confesso che anche essere
qui per me oggi diciamo tra parte della
valanga
adesso noi vorremmo che questa valanga
continuasse si sviluppasse sempre di più
fino ad arrivare a vedere di rimuovere
effettivamente la plastica e provare a
risolvere questo problema ancora non
siamo a quel punto però ovviamente la
valanga sta proseguendo ora vi voglio
dire quello che ho imparato da questa
lezione da tutta questa storia
il primo concetto è che il non mi
riguarda è un pessimo concetto ovvero
noi siamo portati a pensare che
conferendo la plastica della raccolta
differenziata abbiamo svolto il nostro
lavoro da bravi cittadini è davvero
perché questo sicuramente aiuta però il
problema è che allo stato attuale noi
riusciamo a produrre
tanti rifiuti in plastica che non
riusciamo ancora a smaltire e riciclare
è questo il problema vero è per questo
che la plastica si sta accumulando in
maniera incontrollata sul nostro pianeta
di conseguenza sarebbe molto importante
fare delle scelte sostenibili quotidiane
per cercare di far sì che questo non
avvenga
ovviamente ci tengo a sottolineare che
io non voglio demonizzare la plastica
credo che la plastica sia un materiale
meraviglioso è valso il premio nobel ad
un italiano a giulio natta un premio
nobel in chimica e sicuramente ha fatto
evolvere tantissimo la nostra società ha
portato tantissimi tantissimo progresso
sociale
però purtroppo la stiamo usando male è
questo il problema quindi anche il
plastic free e deve essere preso con le
molle
sì plastic free bisogna solo cercare di
evitare la plastica in eccesso e quella
usa e getta in particolare ho imparato
che l'uomo che muove una montagna inizia
spostando piccole pietre ovvero noi
pensiamo sempre che quello che facciamo
noi in senso lato non abbia molto valore
però in realtà sono i nostri piccoli
gesti quotidiani che poi riescono a
smuovere le montagne
ho imparato che è importante accendere
le candele che abbiamo perché altrimenti
quell idea rimane nella nostra mente e
non la utilizzerà mai nessuno
non è detto però potrebbe essere un'idea
che può cambiare il mondo
quindi dobbiamo sempre trovare la forza
di accendere queste idee e di portarle
avanti fino in fondo per provare a
cambiare le cose
ricordatevi sempre che abbiamo un tempo
molto limitato in questa vita
cerchiamo di sfruttarla
ho imparato anche che speranza e volere
che qualcosa accade coraggio e cercare
di farlo accadere
vi assicuro che fare questo salto non è
stato molto facile per me
anzi probabilmente è stata la cosa più
difficile che abbiamo fatto nella mia
vita
questo richiede coraggio impegno tanta
forza di volontà
però poi vi posso anche dire che dopo
aver effettuato questo salto vi posso
dire che la vita inizia nel momento in
cui iniziamo a investire sulle nostre
idee piuttosto che sulle nostre paure
adesso io la mattina mi sveglio sempre
mezz'ora prima del suono della
sveglia ed inoltre ad essere i miei
bambini sanno che la loro mamma sta
cercando di salvare pesciolini nel mare
ed inoltre quando uno studente mi chiede
che cosa si fa all'università per
cambiare le cose
io rispondo sempre che all'università
spostiamo le piccole pietre per cercare
di spostare un domani le montagne grazie
per la iii
[Applauso]